all right New York City's Democratic
mayor Eric Adams calling out the liberal
Governor of Colorado for busing more
migrants to the Big Apple but critics in
the left-wing media not cheering the
outrage ignoring the story uh Far Cry
from how they responded a few weeks ago
and months ago when Governor Ron
DeSantis of Florida did the same thing
chatter now that what these Governors
including Ronda Santos have done is to
have trafficked these these families
it's just cruel and it's sick and it's
sadistic it's a stunt using human beings
to score political points yes human
beings joining us out of react Newsweek
Deputy opinion editor Bhatia Unger
Sargon Bhatia first off we saw in
Colorado he says well we're just going
to ship them to New York City because
this is just a Transit point no one
wants to stay in Denver why does why is
there a double standard here well first
of all uh when Governor DeSantis shipped
migrants North he shipped them to
Martha's Vineyard right he exposed the
hypocrisy of the leftist elites who
claimed to be Sanctuary cities who claim
to welcome the immigrants right and then
the second they got there they called
the National Guard to ship them out
right whereas when they come to New York
City they're competing with low wage
low-income Americans for limited
resources right you can understand the
outrage here's the thing though the the
Democrats like to talk about immigration
in moral terms as though this is somehow
compassionate to have an open border
nothing could be further from the truth
it is unbelievable cruelty to the
migrants themselves who become slaves to
the cartel cells to low wage and to
working class Americans whose wages are
undercut by this influx of low-wage
Labor they talk about it in terms of
morality but they think about it in
terms of economics and Nancy Pelosi made
that so clear when she said we need
these migrants to pick the crops you
remember that she admitted that the
Democratic party sees these these
migrants as an answer to a tight labor
market that without these migrants would
be benefiting the working class with
higher wages was also is true to
Governor Abbott gets ripped all the time
for shipping for busing voluntarily a
lot of these illegals into New York City
now the mayor of New York City says it
is going to break us is going to
bankrupt the city why does he not make a
call to the president United States and
tell them that now mayorka says
yesterday that the massive migration
numbers are straining our system that is
the understatement of the century but it
shows he's no longer saying the border
is secure absolutely at least they're
not lying about that anymore right the
border is not secure the border is open
the cartels know it the migrants know it
and the Democrats know it the problem is
is that leftist Elites benefit
economically from Mass migration that's
why they don't do anything about it
because at the end of the day they are
the ones employing these people in their
homes in their Landscaping businesses in
their restaurants in Liberal cities
these people are finding work when they
get here they're undercutting
working-class American wages why do you
think the president's going to the
border now and what do you think changes
after he goes you know know I hope he's
going now because he feels that he has
the political capital on his own side to
do something about this that's what my
real hope is is that he's had a bunch of
wins the midterms turned out better for
the Democrats than anyone expected and
so he's going to use that Capital to
address this problem that's my hope
that's called leadership yeah and put
partnership aside but if he goes to a
docile area that's just been cleaned up
that's antiseptic and he's there for a
couple of hours it'll make things worse
because he'll say I've been to the
Border not that bad and this is where
Fox News comes in because you guys show
the truth and you show what's happening
there and Bill malusian leads the charge
along with Chris Jenkins I think batia
great to see you and I'll talk to you
over the weekend Saturday I'm Steve
Ducey I'm Brian Kilmeade and I'm Ainsley
Earhart and click here to subscribe to
the Fox News YouTube page to catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis